so with CM Punk let's say and he loves
he wants to be a five he wants to do
this sort of why if you want to be a
fighting you want to do this
come spar over it no hold on you can't
you can't say it's about the purity of
the sport and you love this sport if you
love the sport you could have went down
so many different avenues if it wasn't
about the five hundred thousand that you
made which you're at the third or fourth
high pace guy on the card without any
experience and then pay-per-view bonus
you're making seven figures so you got
paid some figures if it's not about the
money and fame and the recognition which
it's not about that this isn't about
this you're wrong it it because if it
wasn't you woulda went and fought at
your level and fired three amateur ranks
or you or like Dana White offer you you
couldn't went through the Ultimate
Fighter and could have earned your
stripes but you want the recognition you
want to belong the club which is it's
[ __ ] tough in this club and man you
gotta have some credential UFC you just
gotta see roster it's like it's like all
those fighters in the world you mean all
those an Olympic wrestlers all those
guys who fought all they're like what
yeah you wanna be part of that but can
you fight clubs kids can take some work
could take some dates and work you just
don't get right in you got right in
about comedy what I love about fighting
you want to be a cop get up I want to be
a fighter while just gonna say what one
of the smartest people I know said
there's two things you can't fake
fighting and comedy and infighting it's
it's never been more clear that it was a
complete [ __ ] show and how many guys and
I see doubt lash and people get mad at
me on Twitter and Instagram say oh just
salty that you see I'm not salty I'm not
salty people go how is it any different
then Tim Tebow or you Tim Tebow go into
baseball are you going from NFL to
fighting let me tell you so fastly let
me tell you something the reason why
it's different is I have a background in
professional collegiate high school
grappling fighting sports competing at
the highest level in the world
world-class level in other sports
correct so that would be considered an
athlete Tim when the greatest college
football players of all time
Heisman winner won the AFC West with the
Denver Broncos National Football League
won a playoff game in the National
Football League played for the New York
Jets star quarterback for the National
Football League
then he goes to first world hard worker
then he goes to baseball and which 22
out of the however many teams want to
sign the guy so he did something right
but he also played baseball high school
and was recruited and drafted out high
school Major League Baseball again that
would be an athletic background see huh
it's a stupid trust me it might be my
Twitter and Instagram feed anything
CM Punk has now listened to me very
clear put down the Cheetos all the
wrestlers who like I thought he had this
but down the [ __ ] put down the nachos
let me tell you something again tell
your mom to stop yelling at you from the
basement now listen he has no athletic
background
there's no athletic background the
equivalent to him finally you see is the
same and this is the only comparison
it's the same as if [ __ ] Bradley
Cooper won the fight in UFC that has
more similarity
CM Punk fighting UFC then Tim playing
baseball if Brad if Bradley Cooper who's
an entertainer who has no athletic
background one fighting you'll see and
they signed him to contract his can sell
fights that's the exact same thing is
letting CM Punk fighting the essenes
I like Mickey gall he has a ton of
potential she has a lot of work to do
sure and he knows that she knows that
sage Northcutt isn't the fight for you
brother let let them build you up sage
is just too much my way too much stage
sage has been training since he was
[ __ ] 14 his dad had you know creatine
and buffalo meat
acai when his ass yeah but he was like
flipping tires when he's three no that's
not the fiber and he hasn't wins in the
UFC fight a fight another guy let him do
that [ __ ] finding a fighter you 2%
yeah you have a name two years I'm Tony
man you're gonna be that guy who beat CM
Punk if they throw you to the veterans
don't be that guy come and you know see
do me a [ __ ] favor he's young he's
off he gets it cuz he's calling guys out
he beat CM Punk so people know who he is
don't throw him to the wolves let him
build because okay because if they throw
him to the 170 [ __ ] wolves just
sitting rivers salivating its murders
row yeah and his career he's gonna be
three and done okay beat CM Punk you
made thirty two grand
right go around and try doing [ __ ]
book signings you beat CM Punk II ain't
happening that's Pete Rosa it turned out
ain't happening now he's got booked
towards her you're right he's 24 years
old he's got a lot a lot a whole career
he's a lot of fighters don't beat a huge
name let's not jump right at sage
Northcutt yeah the grand I'd love to see
the fight not a good fight for you build
him up but you knew you're seeing I said
that Ed Soares always told me net source
who's a phenomenal manager probably the
best in the world
everyone Anderson Silva Nogueira's
clover everyone he goes where I thought
about Glover verse I forget someone I
went god it's a bad fight for him and he
goes Brendan it's the UFC if you can't
beat everyone you shouldn't be there if
you don't have some advantage over
whoever they throw our way you shouldn't
be there let's get good why was he
running I feel like I feel like Alistair
Oberon doesn't believe he's like you
have to decide believe that you deserve
being a chance steroids a hell of a drug
bryan callen my pee might be also that
he was looper rain would have done to
steep a you know what uber am who was
that who you went about [ __ ]
destructor of a man a guy who Oh Oh
Brock you have whatever [ __ ] deburr
colitis where the [ __ ] it was in your
gut I'm particularly kick in the gut
yeah yeah and you walked through that
over him beats anyone in the world
yeah the over him that we saw he was
scared he was on his bike he he looked
like me at Metamora see inside look like
he was he wasn't running like me it
looked like he was relaxed and ate like
a baby scared I guess I'm sure for you
but it looked like you it looked like he
knew that steep a wants to get him
against the cage and go to work that's
what he paid does his best work when
he's going forward your backs a cage
then he does work from takedowns
everything goes to work so I think you
thought if I get my back cage I'm gonna
use footwork and circle out when I say
footwork I don't mean get on your bike
and run away he literally looked like me
and metamoris so what is that what is
that footwork what is that what is I
don't know do we don't I don't know what
that is
there's no school and [ __ ] the
Netherlands America California
it was straight up running there but it
was also a weight it was also a lazy jog
it's like the kind of jog you do when
somebody's like like a stoplight and the
light is angry and you got a run but you
don't really run you kind of just kind
of jog Dane Cook has a bit about that
where he just kind of jog slowly yeah he
was doing the hey thanks for holding
your car like no sense of urgency now
let me just ja I was like what the [ __ ]
is going on let me tell you the B think
about this he how long is you know about
this fight twelve weeks at least
thirteen weeks yeah someone came up with
that game plan which was to run if
you're bad see it's a cage you're right
we had I'm a counter striker so when my
but when my back foot would go past that
black line or touch the cage you Circle
out use footwork you circle out you take
angles you sure got no one in the
history of fighting us I need you to
turn your back and [ __ ] run get to
the center of the cage turn your back
and [ __ ] and run but I go but take a jog
take a lap but I'm Alistair over take a
lot go but I'm but I'm Alistair okay
take a lot I'm probably the most
technical striker in the heavyweight
division of all time have you seen my
credentials I get that here's what we're
gonna do forget all that stuff but I
like I've won four in a row man beat
some of the very best in the world again
I get that here's only do you're gonna
come out to the pride anthem to me sick
you come out of the pride anybody
wearing Reebok when I put you in Reebok
you're gonna walk out to the Octagon now
when you get in there I want you to look
like you're fighting that k1 I want you
to give them that [ __ ] the ream stare
you know I'm talking about we need the
ream stare then you guys touch gloves
I'm gonna need you to turn your back and
run excuse me I'm gonna need you turn
your back and run don't [ __ ]
take your lap lap it up lap it up take
take a lap don't throw throw a couple
shots now run youngest gold medalist in
wrestling cup guys ever correct how old
was he 22 he's 22 20 wedding and he won
a gold medal in the he's wrestling guys
yeah he's got some guys hit 33 like
wrestling for so much longer than him
too
yeah guess who's fighting the EOC your
boy Kyle Snyder he's coming in he says
what camp
Damon Martin talked to him this morning
so we talked to him today said he said
that he wants to start incorporating
boxing and jujitsu into his training
immediately Wow he's like I'm in and you
know his game planning game plan is of
course for young got the crazy at work
ethic he wants to simultaneously win a
gold medal while fighting in the EOC he
can do that you do that and he wants to
one another world championship so if his
plan worked out perfectly for him he'd
be a two-time world champion I think
don't call me on that pretty sure it's
to time to time world champion two-time
Olympic gold medalist and simultaneously
be a UFC fighter greatest American of
all time he's 20 what wait wait
obviously heavyweight obviously for sure
damn it
but let's think about hey come on have
you seen him no oh my god big boy I saw
a picture of I saw him like I never seen
him ever seen I've never seen him I saw
him I thought he was a fight very small
no I just saw his face I didn't know how
big so uh thank God we have a young
prospect the land of dinosaurs
heavyweights land of dinosaurs there's
20 year old Olympic gold Nellis
he's gonna [ __ ] destroy people God
I'm rooting for that kid God do we need
them look he's gonna take his time too
because the Olympics aren't until 2012
or sticker so he's gonna take three
years well MMA you got to take your time
MMA is a little bit different than
wrestling in terms of like 25 when
you're a gold medal winner you give that
guy two years he beats 95% lecompt is in
the AFC right now really it's very
different thing though thank be so Cain
Velasquez yeah couldn't hold a torch to
this kid Daniel Cormier couldn't hold
torch this kid wrestle you talk about
wrestling
yeah tie my wrestling those got Daniel
Cormier I mean he started doing it not
even to you quickly blasquez not even
really yeah a guy of that level who's
dealing wrestling is a form of combat
for sure it's gonna in if he's an
athlete and gets with the right coaching
you 2 years that guy this ain't simple
different things ain't see and Paul they
once he won a real athlete from real
wrestling looks like in two years with
world-class work ethic you know [ __ ]
some people up man
my money's on that kid with his work
ethic how about getting that kid 5 years
to strike and he has a plan ladies and
gentlemen we have well many would say
one of the best pound-for-pound fighters
ever would be many I say everyone I was
gonna say here a couple guys TJ
Dillashaw his lovely wife Rebecca you
don't know who he is run your face into
your car as you're listening to this
he's one of the very best in the world
our friend TJ Dillashaw up in the fire
kids studio I thought for sure because
the the sense a fight that they gave you
I thought the bigger play there was
u-verse you're right I thought that was
gonna happen so as soon as I lost about
the crews which I thought I should still
have it we also thought you won here
appreciate it I uh I went met with Dana
and Lorenzo and Shawn Shelby they all
told me that they thought I won the
fight and they they didn't really
understand it and so that was kind of my
case like look I want I want this title
fight that I we're working through some
things let you know in a couple weeks I
thought for sure they were going to
match up me and Uriah you're I got the
title fight loss so I thought I thought
for some reason still there would be a
fight there between medium just because
of the money fight that's the story it's
also you're such an exciting fighter so
I'm very puzzled by it's not even that
yeah it's all about Jesus excited
fighter but the story between him riots
Alison self yes not anymore
I mean the guy's not I mean there's no
point for me to fight the guy now and
it's kind of over now it's over
completely over because he lost 12 he
was also number 12 ranked guy I mean Jim
Rivera is tough I knew it yeah Jimmy
were a lot of people at home and who
Adam Wright 12 the cheeto fingers Lawson
forever yeah and so him at 12 so that's
a tough fight for your iron man and you
know I still think your eyes top five
guy right now but as far as your guys's
story it's tough yeah for sure you know
what the play is right what's that if
you didn't get Dominick Cruz which I
hope you do and God willing hopefully
Dana White gets his [ __ ] together I mean
you might get CM Punk I don't what
they're gonna do that's the one might
get Mickey Gaul
no shame and there's a one thing that's
kind of that kind of pissed me off with
the UFC in this whole deal is it it's
it's not about the sport
love with you know when I when I fell in
love with him MA and in fighting it was
completely about to support to baddest
man's on the plant when is it Chuck
Liddell out there he didn't have no
clothes crap to get the fight he just
went out there and performed and was the
baddest man on the planet so they gave
him the fights he was deserving you know
now it's all about how much trash you're
gonna talk and what drama is
entertainment you're selling I know I
know fighting is entertainment but it's
more of the the drama of reality TV than
it is an actual sport and more and it
really kind of just disheartens it for
me it almost makes you want to say like
[ __ ] this I'm not that kind of person
I'm not gonna go out there and it'd be a
little it would look too fake if I'm
gonna go out there and try to go out of
my way to be a Conor McGregor until
nothing is worse my man nothing's worse
when a guy who that's not in his nature
to talk [ __ ] like that yeah and he tries
just like oh my god hey I can't give you
the fight be I mean don't you just keep
brilliant but with you the if for
whatever reason let's say Dominick still
isn't ready by the end of the year even
early next year which you should
completely wait for for that title shot
I wouldn't take anything else besides
that title shot if but if he's out for a
year like sure you know that well I
guess I doubt they'd do that but it'd be
Kody garment yeah I mean long way out
Fighting's for the belt you know if it's
for the belt in her belt whatever it is
like that's home fight I mean so I just
fought number two ranked fighter haw
fail since out on an eighth fight win
streak I forgot even though I was ranked
number one so number one beast number
two where do you go from there a guy
like CM Punk or you see how much money a
guy like Connor McGregor makes and then
you see the Union talk and you don't
have I'm not trying to control me in
this stuff yeah but with a with a union
or even if the fighters band together
when you see a guy like Connor McGregor
can make whatever 12 million then you
see how long you've been doing it or you
see a guy like CM Punk who's probably
gonna make seven figures as well he is
flat for you is 500 and then with
sponsors and pay-per-view hope I make
seven figures stuff like that and you
can see the disgruntled UFC kind of
grouping of fighters like throwing shade
at them but I don't think it's because
you guys dislike seeing Punk and I don't
dislike seeing none oh it's just when I
see the amount of work a guy like TJ
Dillashaw puts in I see these other guys
that's an issue
I mean over a lifetime that's that's i
CM Punk would irritate you more than
Conor McGregor does cuz Connor created
what he's making yeah he's got a whole
country behind him he does a great job
at trash-talking if I talk um fights up
in he knows they Aldo in 13 seconds yeah
so him getting backed it up he backs it
up yeah that's another story cuz that he
came in he's making more money than me
off his first fight in the UFC you know
now it's done was tough to swallow until
you get to know the guys that they'll
start like knocking soft if they know
they're gonna come to the door but they
cut that first time they came they power
they don't sound like they're gonna kick
down in a weird he go thing that's a
nice little didn't come into the door
that's [ __ ] cool how cool would it be
if ten minutes before cuz you're a
douche in ten minutes you get a text it
goes yo TJ this is Gary with you sada
I'm gonna come test you please be ready
cool come the door what's up TJ just hit
for the piss might take some blood I
don't know what they do these days piss
blood yeah so you're just some semen and
feces yes for my personal supplies but
so they do gets me on mouth I have to do
it saliva swab like why not just be cool
but there's this ego thing you see with
you guys where they have where they
think they have a sense of power if they
did over the bat they really don't over
the baddest man on the planet sir you're
collecting my blood and urinate at 6:00
in the morning an oversight or overreach
it's not this crazy what what so that
now they're kind of cool but at first
they wanted they they I would be so
pissed about that way the first time I
did it was it was crazy I mean we don't
have children Craig you wake my baby up
I will you know what you need your urine
I'm gonna piss down your throat yeah
it's so to get my kid to sleep if you
wake that kid up that's how I'm at Brown
wasn't answer because he's got a little
kid he's got some twins as well and they
you know wake up the whole family when
they're knocking on the door good luck
with that
they knock that like they bang on the
door like that oh yeah like they sound
like the straight-up like you've done
something wrong police coming again I
would lose my [ __ ] mind on on those
guys who do you think you are
don't knock on my [ __ ] door like that
but there's a better way to go about it
this is just such like like I had a
business transaction I won't give the
details of it but the guy called me and
literally was just name-calling being
nasty and so cool
man grown-ass man 40-something kids
businessman Yellin blah blah blah blah I
just hang up he's can't blowing my phone
up blow my phone up so I give it like an
hour and I call him back and he's like
what [ __ ] Mike let me ask you
something man do you really think this
is the way to get business done did you
really think someone would respond
positive to this or and I'm completely
down to talk with you about this and
figure this out or do you want to talk
to me like it like a man I'm gonna
figure this out things like goddamn
you're right man like yeah there's no
need for them what's wrong with you
who's gonna respond to that yeah my
problem is that sometimes certain people
get into a position and they are more
into getting off on this kind of power
than actually doing their job become
cops and just people or TSA line shoes
to this yeah [ __ ] I've been the airport
1,000 times you don't need to yell the
more power you give to your authorities
government human beings forget cops as
human beings and you give them power
over you they're gonna take power and it
corrupts you and that's why the wrong
people there's some guys and you saw
they're actually really cool of course
yeah find me I'm assuming I'm now dealt
with them but then there's some cops who
are really cool with TSA someone were
awesome and then some be like dude you
don't have a gun human beings you don't
even have a gun you have no
qualification to even be here you guys
have never caught anybody ever well it's
a human beings I off you don't have a
bomb in my shoes saw me some people when
they get into position figure it out
badge and stuff they're gonna take
advantage of I mean I did an interview
about I think after the first time I got
a drug test and I like talked about how
crazy wasn't Trump the dorm being dicks
about it and then ever since then
they've been cool so he must have like
listened to the interview and they need
a reality check you know they need a
reality check and he follows me on
social medias oh that's cool
I called him out and then now he's a lot
nicer when he's on my bad bro he brings
cupcakes and [ __ ] funny what's up man
here take a cup cuz they have to look at
it right oh yeah I mean he's got to do a
lot more than watch me pee so one
morning he came and I could not pee I
just I couldn't do it and I was like
[ __ ] you know he's like oh you're gonna
have to show you won't be able to pee
unless you [ __ ] and so and I was wearing
like a row
I had nothing underneath okay doctor and
so I hold a plastic bag under your room
I had to like do up completely but Nick
it has to stand in the best small
bathroom standing in the bathroom wall
I'm taking a [ __ ] so I can piss it the
cup of the same socks
imagine that guys jump oh yeah how you
doing everybody healthy bowel movement
huh yeah what else he's very fit he's
got a really hot body this is an
interesting little ogj spot Dillashaw
huh I just came with your [ __ ]
nickname how would I blame TJ TJ
Towanda's smooth Barbie TJ them help a
hurry DJ the human tear the human Ken
doll TJ the delicious yeah I don't know
if you've met it's Rob LA I don't know
why I noticed but you know have you
noticed with the Barbies that they have
all races now like theirs as well maybe
it was sure oh no they have like
transgender Ken now I'm pretty sure that
like a Ken and he's in the thing just
like well Kent's always been gay how do
you know he has always been caged Oh
Barbies his side no oh he's been gay
[ __ ] he shaves his arms he shaves his
chest he shaves his legs he has no hair
on him although I know and well so now
we have to be hairy to be hairy
TJ smooth as a pedal sue this saddle
leather Dillashaw oh we got better ones
by dropping knowledge he started doing
those like my driving knowledge is that
deer and horses in the wild will eat
[ __ ] birds if they can sometimes I
think that's the exception brother I
don't think I don't think father dies
very much the exception exception like
didn't the time when he said he was dead
so she's like do you know how many
penguins a polar bear can eat in the
wild and then I don't [ __ ] know I
haven't been to [ __ ] biology or
zoology and since her sixth grade if he
goes
86 on it god damn that's all
two minutes after the show there someone
saw it I had fifth-graders been like can
you let Brian know polar bears and pings
don't live on the same [ __ ] area on
the earth the same side of the earth
once around or swing on the south yeah
yeah you lied and then I go bro would
you give dropping audios my daughter on
the way she's seven yeah I was
embarrassed and then then I Gilbert you
gotta do better drop knowledge is no
problem I got you in hey guys do you
know the secret ingredient and dr.
pepper
prune juice it is correct Brendon very
good sure enough song goes hey just so
you know directly from dr. pepper there
is no prune juice in dr. pepper my
conspiracy is that it is prune juice but
they just don't want to admit it well
that can be a dropping on Shelby we
could call it conspiracy theories or we
call it [ __ ] Brian here's the next
one should be called true and false this
is true without your fun true true or
false ready it costs more to make a
penny your father
it could false it cost more to make a
penny than a penny true what do you say
false it's true